you
I was working in the lawyer's office
said enough now I met you write this
novel and I witnessed to see my boss mr.
Hill and I said mr. Hill again she leave
you and I need to write it over at which
of course is thought about lovely
I looked at the Attic my god this book
is two-thirds Jerome she's perfectly
United suddenly sit so I cut off me yeah
so that nobody needed an attendance to
the cross is seen just like that and now
people say it was a beautiful structure
it has they only knew how all the tree
that was I sent short stories to Curtis
Brown the publisher and kid it's a hey
wrote and said have I got a novel and I
wrote and said yes but it was bought for
Pfizer hattiesburg she said she's never
seen anything so disgraceful on her life
and she said telegram remember telegram
to him and said it's released this
writer at once or I shall shame you
before your inter not that he would of
care he was a cook I wrote short story
which no publisher then was pleased
about and then I just set off one after
the other and this is what I was doing
and I did think I said now I am a writer
I was a spoon it's just it's just
different it was completely different
then you know you invent those sections
or something and then later sandberg
refer wants to know which is true what
isn't and you have to sit and think you
can't remember anymore so new a lot of
it is invented and half of it is true in
true and inverted commas but everything
you write is is altered in some way it
didn't do any good for feminists we
never like it was very extreme feminist
at that time you know I remember going
to Sweden and some actress coming up to
me and saying this is my book it is not
your book it is not yours I only read
the blue notebook so
kind of exaggerated hysterical rubbish
yeah
life goes on without me so
music